Calvin's with us
Calvin is in Vermont hey Calvin how are
you hey good Dave thanks for taking my
call I appreciate all that you and your
team do Thank You Man
how can I help so my wife and I we have
we're in a house they're listening to
and they're getting on on the baby steps
and just looking at what we should be
spending where as far as soon as it's
over a little over the weekend debating
on selling it looking for your opinion
on it so how much is your house
arraignment 1987 a month okay and what
is your take home pay sixty five
thousand your take-home pay is five is
oh six thousand dollars a month on side
one thousand forty four I'm sorry those
numbers don't go together huh your
monthly take-home pay after taxes after
I'm sorry 5400
okay that's okay it's okay and so your
house payment is 20 percent of your
take-home pay if you follow me yep and
we say don't be over 25 percent so I
don't think your house payments out of
line how much is your car payment I
don't have one good you have any other
debt other than the house no okay and
how many children do you have - how long
you been married
we have been married for six years
28 29 31 31 close enough okay
cool all right the only thing I hear
missing in this equation this should not
be a tight budget with what you just
described you should have all kinds of
room in this budget five thousand four
hundred - less than $1,000 987 house
payment should leave you four thousand
four hundred dollars for lights water
food and taking care of a couple kids
that should not be out
line in Vermont so I think you're
probably not on a written plan
yeah our taxes are 600 years does that
not built into that house payment no
it's okay so that's another $500 on the
house payment all right and how much is
your insurance
it's about 863 a year okay all right and
so if we had another 600 bucks to your
house payment now we've got a real house
payment she have a $1,600 house spending
on a 54 now approaching 25 percent
actually touch over 25 percent so but
it's still not house poor house poor
would be if your house payment including
taxes and insurance was 50 percent of
your take-home pay and I run into that
all the time and you can't breathe when
you do that or 40 percent you can't
breathe when you do that in your case
that'd be like a almost a $3,000 house
payment okay so still I'm gonna make the
case that you're probably not doing your
written plan because a written budget
get on every dollar comm and download
the app it's free to use takes about 10
minutes let your budget out go over it
with your spouse the two of you decided
you're going to tell every dollar what
to do before the month begins when you
give every dollar an assignment before
the month begins and then you stick to
that and it'll take you about 3 cycles
about 3 months to get it dialed in your
first month you'll suck at it
second month you'll be a little better
third month you'll be an expert okay
takes a little bit of time and then when
you get that dialed in you're gonna call
me back and go being on a budget makes
me feel like I got a raise because the
efficient organized use of the money
makes you feel like you've gotten a lift
because you did get a lift you can do
this dude hang with it